paulownia yes Network Yankee analyst
five-time World Series champion and won
the batting title in 1994 Paul good
morning how are you how are you things
are going well looking forward to the
games yeah can you overhype the Yankees
and Red Sox not really I mean it just I
was you know watching them go into the
wild-card game this is really the way it
should be I mean they're really they've
been the two best teams in the American
League and they should fight it out and
I mean it's just to see how this series
goes I was surprised that the Yankees
are slight favored in this series why is
that you go over yeah if you go over
position by position but you know if you
look at the way these teams have played
and they played a lot this year there
hasn't been a lot of close games and I
would expect that this series is a
little bit different because the
pitching you know you're playing for the
game instead of playing for the season
like you do during throughout the year
but you know the Yankees are strong in a
lot of positions but you know Mookie
Betts and and Martinez they literally
change the whole game if you let them
beat them and I think that the Yankees
have to make somebody else beat them
other than those two who is more
overlooked the Indians or the Astros
probably Indians you know the Astros you
know it's hard to be overlooked when you
just want to want championship the year
before but the Indians just because they
weren't pushed all year know if you go
by you know player by player you know
they're an extremely good and talented
young team with some of the better
players in all of baseball and you know
Francona obviously one of the better
managers also so they're very dangerous
and you know you get in these short
series who's hot there's not it can
change the whole look at things I'm also
curious about that to Paul that it's a
five-game not a seven-game series who
does that benefit with the Yankees and
the Red Sox I personally think it
benefits the Yankees I think that their
top three match up very well you know
when you got Happ Severino and Tanakh
I think that you know that you can use
that in a five-game series where a
seven-game series a lot of times you
have to throw another starter in there
and you know David Price he's a
phenomenal pitcher but is he a question
mark in this series going into Game two
he is and you know there is Kristen Alec
a question mark you're gonna see in the
first any if he's throwing 90 miles an
hour free so 97 so you know there there
there are some differences in their
offense I mean New York if they hit home
runs as they did in the wild-card game
then they're very hard to beat you know
but if they're you know not hitting home
runs Boston has a true advantage because
they've got 300 you know 300 hitters
that can produce runs by just getting on
base and getting hits I'm gonna let you
start your team with anybody from the
Yankees Red Sox roster you have the
first pick well you know I'm pretty
biased because I do call the games but I
just think Aaron judge really makes
everybody else around him a lot better
I obviously Mookie Betts is a phenomenal
player and he does so many things out on
the field but I know personally Aaron
judge makes a team of 25 a lot better
best playoff picture you faced was who
well I tested that yeah my toughest if
that was always Randy Johnson and it
just you know you walk up there to the
plate knowing that you chances are you
you can't hit this guy I mean he was
just so dominant on the left side that I
couldn't pick up the baseball and you
know it just it was not a funded bat
where there was regular season or the
playoffs but you go up there thinking
you can't hit him like not the best
mindset to have you know you can only
fool yourself so much I mean you walk up
there at the on deck circle thinking I'm
gonna dig in and really hit this guy in
the first bit you don't even see it so
it hits the catcher's glove and you know
everything he's been telling you so for
the last five minutes is gone you know
there there were times where you know
you faced Pedro Martinez
and there were at-bats where you
literally felt like you had no chance
but then there were that's where you
know you put wood on the ball and you
had a good at that and Brandi Johnson I
don't think I ever had a good at-bat did
you ever think about batting
right-handed yeah I would have done the
same strike out the strike out where
this for the right side to the left side
yeah it's it was no fun how long did it
take when you got to the Yankees for you
to understand the rivalry or you know
how you felt about the Red Sox you know
it was basically spring training of the
first year you get traded over there
it's just that you you feel the
tradition you you see the players that
were before you mr. Steinbrenner I mean
had certain things in order even in
spring training
you know we're games really don't matter
it was very important that you beat the
Red Sox and you beat the Rays because
they were employed also so it you know
mr. Steinbrenner didn't care for spring
paying or not yeah you were expected to
win those games did anybody ever call
mr. Steinbrenner George Steinbrenner any
any of the players yeah I mean boomer
Wells yeah well he could get away with
it I'm just curious because even now you
know everybody talks with such you know
reverence with George Steinbrenner that
it's always mr. Steinbrenner yeah I mean
I had heard that you know he had really
metalled out by the time that you know
that the team's got together in the 90s
and 2000 and I can't have enough respect
for the guy because when I came over it
seemed like you know he had as much on
the line as far as winning and losing as
a team did and you can't say that about
a lot of general managers and owners and
anything we ever needed to win he would
go out and try to do and to me that was
the mark of a good owner I was curious
about the Dodgers approach to the Braves
you know that you don't have Clayton
Kershaw going in Game one and then
Clayton Kershaw said
yesterday in a press conference he has
nothing to prove these guys were great
during the regular season how do you
explain whether it's bad luck or
coincidence that some of the greatest
pitchers of all time have not been great
postseason pitchers yeah I think that it
gets broken down that way and it's not
just in baseball it's in sports I mean
the period I mean you look back at you
know John Elway before he won the Super
Bowls it was the same thing it was Jim
Kelly it just it goes along with sports
because people remember who wins but you
know if you're a great pitcher you're a
great pitcher do you get it in your head
after you've had numerous bad outings
probably and do the media write about it
and then you start to believe it
probably but you know I'm sure that the
Dodgers if they had a game 7 in any
series who would be very confident with
Kershaw on the mouth I mean his numbers
they speak for themselves but you know
David Price is Cana in that same boat as
far as you know yet to really dominate a
playoff series but then you go to
Schilling like what there's certain guys
who just become bigger they become
faster they become strong there is just
something about it that maybe they're
just entertainers they love this stage
there how do you explain Schilling or
Smoltz something you know Jack Morris
some of these guys that just they love
the moment they weren't afraid yeah I
think that you know your last comment
they weren't afraid and you're the
ability of not being afraid and being
able to concentrate at a great level
without being overwhelmed and those
situations kind of make you break you
but there are guys that that are just
better under pressure I mean Derek Jeter
to me you couldn't tell if there's
opening day overs Game seven of the
World Series his demeanor never changed
where you know you can see some players
you know squeezing that bad and trying
to force things because you want it so
much in playoffs and World Series that
sometimes it backfires and you know
fortunately you know if you were with
the Yankees you had a lot of
opportunities year after year to you
know have to make up for a bad series
where you know a lot of players you go
to the
maybe once in your career and you don't
have a great world series then it's
written like you know what hey you
didn't you didn't produce under pressure
but unless you you know you have a
little larger sample size it's very hard
to judge somebody whatever your former
teammates told me about another one of
your teammates that if he struck out he
wanted to make sure he looked good
striking out did you know a rod that
that a rod if he was going to strike out
wanted to look good striking out you
know there was it's funny and I noticed
that people are and you know you're
almost embarrassed back in the 80s and
the 90s if you struck out now guys guys
walk back to the dugout with their
chests you know maybe I'll hit in the
homerun
next time that part of the game has
really changed to where you know you
felt defeated III just got blown away
and struck out and it was almost
embarrassing where at this day and age
is not you can strike out three or four
times and then hit a home run and alls
forgotten and at that part of the game
has really changed good to visit with
you Paul and we appreciate your time
hope you're doing well all right I
appreciate a man always good talking to
you that's Paul O'Neill yes Network
analyst he won the World Series five
times for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]